[Applaudissements]
je me plais annoncé
bouger
j'aurais beaucoup de gens
faire sentir
il faut partir
le soleil
[Musique]
je
demain
janice
à l'ena là on est parti on est parti
pour faire un petit festival est tout
aussi bon accueil à la mort cas de
google c'est parti
non
[Applaudissements]
sofitel
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je sens
à 100
[Musique]
m
ancien
oui et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ses toiles
alors pour finir jaune s'est porté
soutenu
je sois
comme jamais personne
le jour c'est à
il ressent le besoin de moi
kopa le rejet de l'autre
[Musique]
tu sais
[Applaudissements]
c'est un
heureusement
allez c'est parti
[Musique]
robbins moi envie de toi
si vous avez vous des sols
votre fils
bonsoir
des contrats sur le plateau on a noté
une petite vingtaine de millions
d'albums comme qsi au delà c'est la
classe cc c'est du lourd comment il va -
françois fellmann oui je suis en pleine
forme servir s'il ne change pas avec les
années c'est toi parce qu'on se connaît
un peu de temps 30 ans un peu les
cheveux quand
on sent bien comme ça elle avait une
tignasse alors moi j'ai envoyé le coach
est toujours aussi beau ben je travaille
nantis superbe et nick c'est la
chirurgie non je voulais quelque chose
c'est que l'on sait on s'était appelés
ya quelques temps et tu m'avais dit non
je peux pas bouger parce que je me sens
pas bien c'était je sais pas c'était
yens 7 7 ans tu as dit je ne vais pas
bien là quand même temps ya sept ans
sept huit ans c'est un ouais mais dit à
ce moment je vais pas bien et je veux
pas me montrer d'accord tu t'en
rappelles
je suis célibataire je bouge
complaisant non non ça c'était pas n'est
pas bien que moi parce que c'était la
loi des séries c'est une mauvaise
période j'ai perdu mes parents on m'a
rendu mon contrat ma fille est elle
s'est éloignée c'est un peu plus
pluvieux que ses traits et puis voilà
alors c'est s étaient récompensés on
refait une santé oms
on y va on est tout à rebâtir et parce
que vous avez croisé un homme way qui va
redonner le chemin jim et comment que ça
se fait vous êtes malade vous savez
grosse maladie et justin ont cessé c'est
une déprime bon c'est une maladie la
dépression et c'est très très bien sûr
il faut dire aux gens justement de 2
c'est pour ça que stromae a fait
d'ailleurs de relativiser certes voilà
on m'a dit beaucoup de marchés près de
l'eau donc du coup je suis parti de
paris je suis très déçu on m'a dit tu
vas rester un an et
vous n'avez jamais remontée annoncée
avant 20 ans que j'y suis j'y suis très
bien on est bien un pari mais deux trois
jours
vous vous êtes très bien paru
françois vous la musique c'est quoi
c'est depuis l'enfance toyer vous savez
jeanneau 4 5 ans après 4-5 ans comme
mozart ou presque
est à 14 ans glace devient comme better
un peu chaud
je pouvais bien articuler nadeau ça
c'est
de faire de commentaire
comment des commandes et des années
mission ce sera déjà pas si mal
présent jeudi au début du sud je vous
adore et vous maniez anvers je vous aime
comme jamais jamais
[Rires]
à l'épaule
premier habitat ouais 80 première
guitare et après vous intégrez le ff yo
yo yo ké lo n'diaye loin de la main
jaune merci épatant roulettes monte
toujours alors que sa grand-mère à la
bombe à mon genre avant après après
simon c et spectacle avec des patins
roulait donc c'était la main jaune un
jour la main je le groupe citée y est
loin d'accord amazon se le sont c'est
pareil la boîte qu'on voyait dans la
boum
et puis à les sous titres s'appelait you
want to win haïti avait été remixé aux
états unis dans le bronx où il y avait
tous les rap que des fins que mène mais
voilà et ça a été un carton et à partir
de 89 la
c2a venger favola d'arrangement comme ça
en fin de compte moi je suis plus un
artiste de studio je voulais pas chanter
moi et avoue que j'ai fait plein
d'arrangement j'avais fait vacances
j'oublie tout tu te rappelles
tu faisais les voit chanter les
arrangements c'est après j'ai fait
je sais pas si je peux le dire latéraux
big apple
ou toniques ou la
wii c'est la
wii
si tu viendras continue avec de ces
fausses aérobic tu vois bien sûr on
présente les charlots et vous avez les
maquettes parce qu'il me fallait quand
même les chansons guitare voix ou piano
voix et me dit c'est quoi je devais les
maquettes tu vois une petite un
répondeur je dis oui à l'époque on avait
des répondeurs et une casquette une
cassette avec leurs annonces et la
cassette enregistrée c'était en 82 sais
pas si vieux 1904 d'accord écrit un
court
débat n'est d'appel ta mère et 82 et
donc
jean sarrus qishan et charles l'année
chardy ne décroche pas à 20 heures je
t'appelle un peu justin bieber et tu
vois et le répondeur vous êtes chez son
papa laisser un message et voilà et
c'est là que me fais c'est l'apéro be a
agi
voici la maquette il faut que ça bouge
la tête ont accepté ça
a été un très beau succès a permis
donc vous partez de loin quand même
parce qu'à la base la paire au mixer
quand même c'est sympa mais c'est à la
course pas d'accroc variété c'est pas
les valses et les oui mais ça avait bien
marché
c'est bien avant d'où ça vient je retire
le bouchon
du quoi je mets les petits glaçons mais
bon à consommer modération bien
évidemment et bien sûr on va se refaire
une conduite parce que c'est vrai que
l'on va pas le nom mais on est là comme
pas pour parler de vous le nombre de
tubes de françois c'est énorme joue pas
petit franck c'est toi qui m'as fait la
val de vienne effet thérapeutique les
problèmes et c'est parti eric pour toi
document
saleh
oh pas pleurer
je ne plus vendre
[Musique]
ma
maintenant 2
[Musique]
tu meurs
oui
pas mal quand même alors les mâles ses
90 et après bon on pense on pense
souvent que c'est les valses ou séries
où je vous parle le plus gros tubes
comment dire commercial non ça a été de
jeunes parfois
vingt dix
[Applaudissements]
vva
nés en 92 j'étais numéro a aussi pas mal
tu donc au total
les chiffres au bas quand même non quand
même si j'y raconte dans une vie
était trois fois numéro un et deux fois
numéro 2 donc j'ai eu les records ce que
j'ai été trois fois numéro a quand même
trois fois le mur alors moi j'ai été
deux fois numéro deux à cause de la
lambada lambada ahsoka
avec c'est toi qui m'a fait très bien
que l'autre et joue pas ça n'a pas lutté
là alors moi je il ya une image je vais
leur passé parce que ça reste un des
groupes plus grands fous rires c'était à
paris je peux pas de balard passé j'ai
hésité mais je vais repasser à le
téléthon
génial
nous sommes au téléthon évidemment c'est
une mission sur le service public sur
france 2 france 3 et avec qui est au
service de tous ceux qui sont atteints
on est en 96 c'est comme ça il ya donc
devant les agresser ses 80 ans en chaise
roulante et évidemment on déprime pour
se mouvoir et françois fellmann arrive
sur scène comme un bateleur et déjà
c'est la cata au diabète
on a bien joué
[Musique]
mais j'imagine parce que un peu c'est ya
rien de grave non on va très bien dans
votre thèse qui se passe c'est que vous
voyez mais en fait c'est donc à personne
c'est aussi ça cet écossais t in sinon
j'ai une association qui s'appelle
sourire et partage
compenser de greg berman d'envoi la paix
dans le sud personne pouvait en vouloir
là bas ça c'est quand l'autre il a fait
l'émission sur tf1 et décortique c'est
comme un morceau de saucisson qu'il
avait cachée
bon l'avenir il a pris ça on ne sait
plus quelle année en 2006 alors que ça
c'est 96 et oui voilà la bonne nouvelle
c'est que monsieur ferraille est en
tournée dans toute la france tout l'été
[Applaudissements]
avec des musiciens très beau plateau il
a dit c'est mon anniversaire est bas
[Applaudissements]
happy birthday
merci départ et nous alors on va passer
maintenant alors moi je veux dire que
gold françois feldman dans ma jeunesse
mais goal c'était quand même énorme
c'était seulement un cumul il ya un
nombre de semaines numéro un pour ces 24
semaines oui constitutive oui numéro 1
cd tu peux en veux tu en voilà et aussi
je dois vous dire c'est pour moi c'est
une séparation mal que je n'ai pas tout
compris
je vais vous expliquer à laval à moi
parce que les gens n'ont pas compris ce
qu'est emile et la jupe après après il
ya vous et gold oui à ma mère et sa
cuisinière
et alain lurquin tout seul et bataille
et voilà donc est ce qu'au départ c'est
une brouille d'affaires ouais évidemment
avoir comme dans tout bon pour moi il ya
toujours un problème de tension d'ego
évidemment donc le chanteur à la
proposition de faire un album solo donc
ils sautent sur l'occasion déjà il ya
quelques tensions artistique entre nous
parce qu'il faut dire qu'on est tous
compositeur et
producteur notre musique bien sûr et
auteur aussi et du coup ça crée des
tensions et puis voilà maison de disques
lui fait du pied donc qui va signer un
solo à tel point que vous ne pouvez plus
reprendre le nom du groupe oui alors il
a fallu qu'on râle quand je parle d'un
gros bazar au bazacle est une marque
déposée par le chanteur et de manager et
du coup il a fallu qu'on rachète la
marque a assez de ces individus on les
aimait bien non ça s'est passé après bon
avec le temps quoi aujourd'hui tous les
membres du groupe ont exploité peuvent
exploiter ou les chansons et chansons
indépendamment mais pas le nom voilà
c'est pour ça que moi j'ai appelé ça
mais en hegoalde quand je vois mes
concerts à un solo je fais mais alain
llorca maison des gold et pourquoi vous
n'avez pas réussi à vous de vous mettre
d'accord voilà on prend
ça c'est compliqué
c'est toujours très compliqué c'est vrai
et voilà et du coup ben comme les années
80 ça remarche énormément j'ai eu la
chance monde et reprendre évidemment le
répertoire en version originale et comme
j'étais un peu la doublure vocale de
gand d'ailleurs que tu es à la basse et
au bachand gbagbo s communistes voilà
voilà voilà je faisais aussi derrière je
faisais aussi des délits d' des solos
des voix solo sur les albums et donc du
coup ça m'a bien servi de champ c'est
dans l'esprit du groupe quoi je veux
garder l'esprit des chansons du groupe
parce qu'on a fait je pense de belles
choses ah oui alors on va regarder voir
est un peu compliqué mais ce qu'il ya
que des tubes voilà c'est ça il ya eu
des progrès
[Musique]
et
rés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aso c'est mort
[Musique]
les opa
c'est
là
à
[Musique]
là encore à la on est autour de combien
d'albums vendus
je ne sais pas les droits sacem
combien on était recettes à partager le
gâteau qu'on
arrivait pas loin de dix huit ou dix
millions de disques vendus tous
confondus quand même pas mal ouais est
ce que vous vivez encore de ses voyages
sûrs et surtout des tournées des
concerts parce que je suis beaucoup
comme sloan de d'avoir intégré la
tournée des années 80 la tournée et
parallèlement je fais toujours mais
existent et remises en hegoalde donc je
fais quand même entre 60 et 80 dates pas
l'aider à tourner à des 80 quand je
crois qu'il n'y a pas tellement aimé
font savoir la tournée la tournée ouais
moi j'ai adoré participer au film
avec steam si génial isa dans la voiture
géniale et puis non c'est pas ça et puis
le stade de france ah oui d'ailleurs pas
soir à bercy j'avais déjà fait 91 3
soirs l'olympia une semaine les ai dit
j'avais déjà fait ça donc j'ai pas été
surpris vraiment j'étais plutôt frustré
de chanter que
c'est ça que les gens c'est qu'on chante
pas tout tout notre répertoire dont on
connaît peu mais il ya une telle
ambiance le talent bien ce que voilà
c'est ça la seule aussi aussi déçu on
est honnête est ce que vous avez pensé
un jour que tous les titres qui ont été
faits dans ces années là un jour allait
revenir à jamais parce que j'aurais
imaginé les 80 et aujourd'hui encore
d'être trop soit passé du grand prix
cécilia il ya un engouement années 80
qui wiki incroyable plus qu'aucune autre
décennie d'ailleurs et c'est surtout que
ça va qu'ils sont beaux et les jambes a
cédé des jeunes adultes qu'ils ont 25 35
ans
et jamais on n'aurait imaginé ça quand
on a fait les chansons bien sûr dans les
années 80 évidemment jamais la tournée
années 80 va reprendre là ce soir vous
êtes abonné à la reprise déjà
la route est donc toujours sur la base
de zénith là oui oui donc ses doigts ou
des parcs et des arrivées à caen ce soir
si ac en fait là vous êtes d'accord en
fait voilà alors on s'y
habitue
avignon j'ai laissé mon
on a des nôtres est très rapide oui donc
s'est tournée des zénith sans lacets
blancs des cibles ndi c'est incroyable
et puis après j'ai mise en hegoalde des
tournées d'été les dates des concerts
d'été des festivals et voilà tout cas
c'est vrai qu'on me contrôler au bois
santé quand on va les voir sur scène
voilà quand on est à 40 50 60 on remonte
le temps et de l'aisne de bons claude ou
pompeux besoin de rien envie de toi si
pour l'année de l'anecdote quand même
c'était la face b d'un disco des oui
c'est à dire qu'il y avait au départ
s'étaient peter qui avait fait un slot
magnifique italiens et les producteurs
ont dit quand même on va pas mettre un
instrumental à l'époque c'est ce qu'on
faisait de la face à en face b et les
producteurs me disent ben écoute tu vas
faire une phase bêta 2 heures tu nous
fais un truc qui bouge
vingt minutes après survenue avec besoin
de rien envie de toi on a fait
l'orchestration dans la nuit puis c'est
devenu de ce mois passé c'est votre plus
gros votre plus gros succès oui mais
j'avais fait des chansons pour carlos et
jérôme les mini star j'ai monté le
groupe le mini star danse autour de la
terre en tant que compositeur j'ai fait
pas mal de choses mais besoin de rien
envie de toi c'est mon gros bébé bah oui
et depuis depuis que vous êtes venu la
dernière fois que vous avez révélé avoir
subi des violences la part de peter du
coup maintenant c'était quoi la suite
juste après cette émission vous avez eu
des retours samedi
est vert un complément la question moi
c'est qu'ils ont grossi que je voulais
poser ya peter qui est allé faire une
émission de télé je crois jordan de luxe
en disant que tu étais mythe au complet
oui oui jamais été avec lui avant un but
avait jamais été ça les juges bancaire
c'était avant qu'elle alors qui a raison
c'est moi c'est est ce qu'on va vraiment
entré dans l'histoire du groupe je suis
pas dans non non le mieux savoir de
retour après tu m'aimes c'est toute la
france qui m'a soutenu voilà ça et de la
part de sa première femme qui m'a
soutenu aussi ça va la faire mais ça m'a
fait beaucoup de bien je vous remercie
parce que j'ai pu parler à coeur ouvert
j'ai eu un accueil fantastique chez vous
et je dois dire que ça m'a libéré depuis
j'ai maigri de 3 kilos donc ça veut dire
que je vais mieux magnifie section
vtt la choriste de télévision vous fêtez
la cloris de céline dion dans son
premier album de tout de tout pour le
tout premier album avec ma petite soeur
pascal richard qui n'est plus là qui
nous accompagne on était toutes les deux
choristes de céline diot dans son
premier album dans la légende dit
qu'elle est toujours restée la même
entre ses débuts est
bien connu au départ mais après non je
suis pas revu mais j'adore cette femme
c'est la plus belle voix du monde pour
moi ces gîtes je suis très fier d'avoir
fait l'écart dans son premier album et
on nous dira de la tournée a été reporté
lorient a été reporté soit dix ans en
2023 on a parlé sur ce plateau la
semaine dernière ce serait enfin on
commence beaucoup à s'interroger sur des
histoires d'assurance qui ferait qu elle
reporte un report tel repas jusqu'au
jour elle nous dira que l animal qu elle
n y mettre en bourse un jours merci
habillement merci slow merci nana
c'est tout
konami avec bien sûr c'est lui